[Applause]
playground Boston goes up by one yes
Mike that's with the left hand
big to step by Mickey and he brings down
the house for the lead
98 97
heck of a pass by the roof rebounding
Jackson
[Applause]
how about
there is the little alley-oop
I mean he is so quick don't sixteen with
a eight-point lead
round two
why not glass to finish but for some way
like on Friday night they make these
miraculous shots over you are falling
down now that this is just you know
acrobatic get kind of playoff feel to it
in terms of the intensity on the court
[Music]
[Applause]
pretty good defense quite your rep code
there up ahead Bradley throws it up the
ground oh what a catch
what heck of a play out in the open
court Bradley throws it up round this
whoa catches it with the left comes down
and switches it up to his right hand
looking down a my number seven the rooks
and also some of these other golf clubs
though started the wound now and you
know make any of their logjam Brown on
the break for the Celtics goes around
the world the circus came in about
Finland he's getting a standing ovation
right now I want to see him duplicate
[Applause]
catches it off he goes
[Music]
[Applause]
selfs don't have to you guys on the
roster who could do this
but Brown came to win a best-of-seven
series after losing the first two games
at home brown barrel and one he is so
active in athletic shooting it at 65%
[Applause]
wonderful turnover
taking advantage Morris high-low action
snap to their background Washington up
by two smart
jaelyn
motion midair and finished on the
reverse there and his Celtics showing
fight showing light here at the garden
Williams who when he first came to
Cleveland see quite a bit of action and
then did not get as strong as he needs
to be but he's 19 and that's going to
come but he has he has a great sense for
the game he has a great sense for the
game he can pass he can shoot he runs
the floor he's athletic he's can test
every shot before a big guy coming into
this league I think that's always a
challenge and from what I saw yesterday
he has a good feel for it defense ways
so I'm really not concerned about his
offense that's going to come because
he's too skilled from now for it to come
tremendous showing here by team world in
team Africa in the second NBA Africa
game 2017 into Tampa
[Applause]
Photoshop there's no two ways about it
[Music]
[Applause]
jaelyn
can
you stepped out of balance take a look
at the good play here but you cousin
brown Oh
let's go special frosting on that cake
[Applause]
defended laneway with a 3-pointer way
off for two tips up like to snare the
hit the pound
should be an easy two
well long rebound both Korver and Wade
come to the board no back for balance
deep points now Brown
[Applause]
thanks to his bangs in there like we
talked about this is off the glass Jalen
Brown jump hang in the air
Jalen it helps if you actually look at
the rim
I know needs gal I got this he's looked
at the ball Suffolk's by one
[Applause]
bummer so the stare he lost him
here comes brown water problem fire she
loved dancing
[Music]
lot of Celtic fans here in DC Morford
with the big follow and the big finish
Jana brown with the steel in the dunk
Boston up three attacking no thirsty
beginning
that was of his lemon juice
[Music]
I put him is mine oh wait the left hand
let's how you shoot some boom here comes
brown smart on one side
[Applause]
what a move here by Brown and the finish
totally defense
[Applause]
[Music]
drove it and really with one tenth of a
second there's nothing they can do to
get a shot for another miss for Bledsoe
he cannot find his stroke here in Boston
[Applause]
he's got him on their feet here at the
garden
three-point line first time you touched
it notice who is guarded here Belinelli
has Tatum Russia him a crown oh okay
[Applause]
look at MB goes up with both thirds
Brown powers it down with the pump and
the steer at Gobert you great catch and
go on the drive powerful finish by Brown
and the staredown you got taken out by
Rozier had a strong night off the bench
just about everybody has had a strong
back at the play there by Browns or to
the drove between legs bit low
right to the basket good job with their
double teams when he does get into that
situation could steal
[Applause]
y'all pick a role for the he Jewish and
extinct over by hey
that leads to a winter timeout
Celtics up by 13
on the weak side board there is brown
whole lotta shakin finish leaving tinkle
a bit of the dust look it it starts with
LeBron James you know when you're
talking about the deepness of effort we
talking about the leadership all men
have to get what he made Phil goes okay
if you're open you shoot it if
somebody's open guys in transition
jaylen Brown the beautiful circus shot
is a nice finish that was impressive he
came putting on his stump watchin Wow
come on people are still sick so I'm not
going to let you do it two times on two
took executive plays what's up you guys
this Taylor Brooks with bleacher report
make sure that you subscribe for some
more video content